bon nous sommes donc partis et bien
bonsoir à tous
merci de m'avoir envoyé toute une liste
de questions beaucoup trop longue pour
ce que je vais pouvoir prêter et je vais
avoir le privilège de prendre exactement
dans l'ordre dans lequel j'ai envie de
les prendre
voilà et alors je vais donc commencer
par une question l'impression de me
retrouver comme grosses dates là un
gouvernement mondial serait il plus
efficace contre le réchauffement
climatique alors la bonne nouvelle c'est
que c'est tout à fait impossible d'avoir
un gouvernement mondial
parce que on en a pas pour le moment et
on en aura pas d'ici à ce que le
problème du climat soit pas réglé
en fait un gouvernement mondial ça
voudrait dire qu'il ya un processus qui
fait qu'à un moment la totalité des pays
du monde sont régis par une seule entité
historiquement il ya eu que de manière
d'arriver à cela c'est la guerre on va
dominer un pays et puis on en prend le
contrôle ou bien les traités qui arrive
à donner un chef à quelque chose qui
fonctionne sur un périmètre restreint
par exemple dans tout petit tout petit
vous ensemble dans le domaine du
commerce mondial quand les pays
s'accordent entre eux à un moment ils
peuvent confier à un tribunal le soin de
trancher les conflits en dix ans va si
on n'est pas d'accord il ya une instance
supérieure supranationale qui va
trancher le conflit pour nous mais c'est
des cas de figure qui sont très
restreints et malheureusement depuis un
traité célèbre qui s'appelle de traiter
de west valley les états sont souverains
ce qui veut dire que en gros ils font ce
qu'ils veulent ce qu'ils veulent chez
eux sauf si on a les moyens de les
envoyer en militairement pour les
contraindre à faire autre chose donc
très souvent on a tendance à espérer
pour régler un problème qui s'exerce
effectivement à l'échelon mondial le
réchauffement climatique on a tendance à
espérer l'apparition d'une autorité
mondiale qui pourraient quelque part
avoir d'avoir de l'influencé ou de
l'impact ou contraindre l'ensemble des
acteurs
à s'en sortir sans ça c'est à dire qu'on
devra enrayer le problème si on arrive à
le régler un jour sans qu on l autorité
supranationale en question après il faut
aussi voir que quand on rêve d'une
autorité supranationale elle peut être
bonne nouvelle est mauvaise c'est à dire
que s'il en est s'il y en a une qui
arrive un jour elle sera pas
nécessairement adaptées aux problèmes à
traiter cette partie des choses aussi
que l'histoire nous enseigne
si on prend l'exemple de la des nations
unies et de la convention cadre des
nations unies sur le réchauffement
climatique
c'est en fait quelque chose qui
ressemble un peu à une assemblée de
copropriétaires son président et sens
indique enfin si avec un président de
circonstance nexans indique donc en fait
c'est une instance qui n'a pas de chef
ou chacun arrive en disant ce qu'il est
prêt à faire et où on essaye après par
consensus de se mettre d'accord dans un
contexte dans lequel la seule chose qui
est vraiment régler quelque part c'est
le temps de parole mais rien d'autre
c'est la raison pour laquelle c'est très
très difficile de faire émerger une
action coordonnée et un peu volontaire
de ce genre d'enceinte où il ya une
forme de ou en gros tout ce qui peut en
sortir c'est des consensus mou et
l'accord de paris on a célébré en grande
pompe et quelque part quelque chose qui
est une auberge espagnole
c'est à dire qu'on s'est mis d'accord
sur le fait que chacun serait ce qu il a
dit qu'il serait prêt à faire voilà
c'est ça en gros la corde pas donc c'est
pas voilà donc c'est cette idée qui
tenait souvent les français d'avoir un
grand chef suprême qui serait
bienveillant et qui serait capable de
régler pour nous des problèmes qu'on n'a
pas envie de régler
hélas il va falloir faire ça
après je vais prendre une question d'une
question mignonne
pourquoi n'êtes vous pas ministre de
l'écologie alors ministre c'est pas dieu
un ministre de l'écologie c'est
quelqu'un qui est d'abord patron d'une
administration
le ministre de l'ecologie il a la
tutelle aujourd'hui enfin périmètre du
ministère de l'eau il a la tutelle sur
l'administration qui s'occupe de
l'énergie il à la cotutelle sur
l'aménagement du territoire il à la
cotutelle sur l'administration qui
s'occupe du logement donc un ministre
c'est quelqu'un qui est un patron d'une
administration et qui à ce titre doit
faire tourner une entreprise qui produit
du texte puisque d'administration c'est
ça qu'elle fait elle produit de la
réglementation et elle applique donc
c'est un métier qui demande un genre de
beauté particulier c'est très difficile
en fait d'être bien en phase avec son
administration est de bien comprendre ce
qu'ils font parce que quand on arrive en
général on arrive parce qu'on a la
confiance du chef pas parce qu'on est
spécialement compétents dans le domaine
à traiter on peut l'être mais c'est pas
une condition nécessaire et c'est un
domaine dans lequel on doit
nécessairement se coordonner avec
d'autres ministres qui ont d'autres
casquettes
il ya des réunions qui sont bien connues
dans le monde ministériel qui sont ce
qu'on appelle les interministériel ils
sont des réunions qui sont faites pour
que justement dit le ministre en se
coordonnent divers ministères se
coordonnent quand il s'agit de prendre
une décision sur un sujet donné et c'est
là en général que se nouent les leçons
alors selon qu'on est un peu caustique
ou un peu bienveillant la coordination
où les bras de fer de manière de dire ça
sur les décisions qui sont qui sont
prises en commun donc ministre c'est pas
un domaine s'est passé pas un job dans
lequel on décide d'un truc
et puis le truc ce fait les lois sont
votées par le parlement il faut le
rappeler
alors certes en france c'est le
gouvernement qui à l'agenda du parlement
et c'est le gouvernement qui fait les
projets de loi donc c'est clair que l'on
peut faire énormément de choses
mais quand on est quand on est du côté
de l'administration mais c'est quand
même pas ministre un job qui permet de
régler tous les problèmes avec son seul
angle de vue qu'ils soient prises en
compte par la collectivité s'est pas
exactement ça voilà donc ça c'était une
réflexion un peu général sur c'est quoi
être ministre cela étant être ministre
s'est aussi occupé l'espace que le
président et le premier ministre ont
décidé de laisser le ministre occupée
donc il ya ce qu'il dit après il ya ce
qu il peut effectivement faire et il se
trouve que la question de la
décarbonation de l'économie si on prend
les le sujet on va dire qu'il m'est cher
c'est un sujet holistique c'est un sujet
systémique s'est insurgé comment il faut
l'appeler c1 c'est un sujet qui touche à
absolument tout seront faits autour de
nous il ya une raison assez simple à ça
c'est que l'énergie étant par définition
les flux physiques s'occuper d'énergie
c'est s'occuper de tous les flux
physiques qui font la société qui nous
entoure donc toucher à ce genre de
choses ça ne peut être qu'un programme
présidentiel et où un programme européen
au sens de sa demande vraiment de
toucher à tous partout et c'est pas
quelque chose qui relève d'un ministre
qui lui a ainsi l'eau dans lequel il est
prié de rester et de ne pas trop
s'occuper de ce que sont ses copains
donc par exemple l'agriculture est un
domaine partagé par exemple l'industrie
est un domaine partagé par exemple
l'aménagement du territoire est un
domaine partagé par exemple la
diplomatie est un domaine partagé en
l'occurrence elle est très peu partagé
par le ministre de l'environnement et
donc le la personne qui a vraiment la
clé et qui est vraiment à me mesure de
décider que la colonne vertébrale
ça va être le retour aux flux physiques
c'est pas le ministre de l'environnement
c'est le président donc la bonne
question à ce moment on pourrait plutôt
être tout en fumant de chevigny l'apport
pourquoi est ce que vous n'avez pas
envie d'être président donc là je pense
que ceux qui ne sont pas en train
d'éclater de rire 30 le reste de la
réponse c'est évidemment quelque chose
que je ferai peut-être dans une autre
vie mais sûrement pas dans celle ci
ça serait totalement ridicule de
prétendre que je peux faire quoi que ce
soit dans ce domaine le on peut tenter
de lui parler au président et du resto
shift c'est ce qu'on essaye de faire
j project donc de temps en temps on
essaye d'approcher l'administration
élyséennes pour leur suggérer des choses
qui nous paraissent pertinentes ou qui
nous paraissent être de nature à changer
le regard qu'on porte sur le problème
traite mais il faut bien voir que c'est
un travail de longue haleine et que
encore une fois c'est un fonctionnement
de la démocratie la personne qui a
vraiment de la marge pour définir une
ligne
c'est au niveau du président alors j'ai
un petit regret avec notre président
actuel c'est que je pense qu'il est en
train de rater le coche
il avait à mon sens un boulevard pour
faire quelque chose d'un peu descriptif
au moment où il est arrivé parce que
toutes les conditions étaient réunies
pour lui les conditions domestiques
étaient réunis parce que il n'avait rien
promis à personne il est arrivé parce
que le précédent de là est sorti il a eu
une chance absolument incroyable ça a
été les dix petits [ __ ] parce que tous
ces candidats sont morts ou se sont
suicidés tout seul les infra tous ses
adversaires pardon les uns derrière les
autres
donc il est arrivé comme un ovni il ne
devait rien aux électeurs
encore une fois il a fait extrêmement
peu de problèmes il ne devait rien à son
propre parti puisque son propre parti et
sa création donc il n'avait pas les
barons qui devait qu'il devait donner
des sucettes et c'est donc sur le plan
intérieur il était libre sur le plan
européen il était libre parce qu'il
avait en face de lui une grande bretagne
en plaindre exit donc qui n'est pas
audible sur la scène européenne
une allemagne et en italie qui sont
empêtrés dans leurs problèmes intérieurs
qui sont en train d'empirer et donc ils
n'étaient que peu audible aussi et une
chancelière allemande
d'abord en fin de mandat puis
aujourd'hui politiquement affaibli et
enfin tous les autres pays sondés trop
petit pays les pays bas la suède et
c'est donc il avait un boulevard pour
proposer quelque chose d'un peu fort
d'un peu lisible et qui tourne autour du
projet dans une europe qui cherche
désespérément
projet et où mes concitoyens aujourd'hui
se contrefoutent de savoir qui on va
faire 3 ou 2 ou 5 ou 3 % de déficit
budgétaire
c'est pas ça qui les fait se lever le
matin enfin il avait un boulevard sur la
scène internationale parce que trump
avait dit ce problème là ne m'intéresse
pas à ses grilles de lecture qui le
retour à la physique ne m'intéresse pas
donc je laisse le fauteuil dans les
autres et donc macro on pouvait faire ce
qu'il a fait dans le domaine de la
recherche mais c'est un tout petit
morceau de ce qu'ils pouvaient faire par
ailleurs macron pouvait faire une opa
sur toutes les forces vives américaines
qui avaient envie d'avancer dans le bon
sens le japon est très peu présent sur
la scène diplomatique internationale
donc c'était pas eux qui auraient envie
d'entraîner le monde dont quelque chose
voilà ils s'occupent de leurs problèmes
les seuls compétiteurs véritable c'était
les chinois donc macron il pouvait
démarrer ce projet et entraîner derrière
lui tout un tas de pays dans le monde et
autour d'un projet je le redis et
derrière commencé à discuter avec les
chinois à la limite à ça c'était qu'il
faut faire de la pédagogie on n'arrive
pas à entraîner les français dans cette
direction sans faire de la pédagogie
donc il faut travailler le fond voilà
donc ça c'est quand même une limite mais
enfin c'est vraiment dommage qu'il est à
mon sens rater cette opportunité parce
que je suis pas sûr que cet alignement
de planètes va se représenter une
deuxième fois dans les années qui
viennent et on a tendance à l'oublier
parce que nos élections à nous
maintenant raison un an et demi mais
enfin l'élection qui vient de se passer
en italie devraient opportunément nous
le rappeler le basculement de la france
vers un schéma beaucoup plus chahutée
que celui qu'on a aujourd'hui n'est pas
du tout à exclure la prochaine
législative ou à celle d'après on va
déjà voir ce que vont donner les
européennes s'est pas complètement sûr
que l entraide l'europe vers plus de
cohésion et un projet qui fasse sens
voilà donc sur sur 7 et 7 longues
digressions derrière pourquoi est-ce que
je suis pas président communiste la
bonne réponse est président français
avec derrière lui des troupes et une
révision
il ya six mois c'était une vraie
opportunité mais clairement je serais
fou mégalomane ou ce qu'on veut si je
pensais que je dois aller jouer dans
cette cour de récréation
voilà il ya plein de questions qui
arrivent par la messagerie alors je suis
désolé je vais être un tout petit peu
légitimiste puisqu'il y avait des tas de
questions qui étaient arrivés avant
l'heure j'en prendrai peut-être dans la
messagerie
si j'arrive à suivre le fil de la
discussion
tiens je vais prendre une question
amusante pas par l'argent du tout dire
est-ce que les pics des combustibles
fossiles sont susceptibles prémunir
contre les pires scénarios du giec
alors la réponse est oui mais ce n'est
pas une bonne nouvelle car aujourd'hui
ce qui fait fonctionner le monde c'est
l'approvisionnement enfin c'est ce qui
fait ce qui est nécessaire plus
exactement une des choses qui sont
nécessaires au fonctionnement du monde
qui nous entoure
c'est l'approvisionnement en
combustibles fossiles parce que c'est
ces énergies disponibles à la demande
qui ne dépend ni du lieu
tant qu'on peut avoir des combustibles
fossiles dans tout endroit de la planète
les transporter de la planète qui
s'affranchissent des conditions
climatiques et géologiques du lieu on
peut avoir des énergies fossiles qui est
des montagnes ou par des montagnes pour
des barrages qui est du vent ou pas qui
du soleil ou pas qu'il fasse chaud ou
qu'il fasse froid donc ces combustibles
fossiles qui ont permis de s'affranchir
de toutes les conditions auxquelles nos
ancêtres étaient été soumis elle est
long en gros on navigue entre 2,2 et
cailloux le premier c'est qu'on en métro
et à ce moment on a la vie douce pendant
un certain temps ces combustibles
fossiles pendant un certain temps soit
dit en passant permettent de résister au
début du changement climatique parce que
le changement climatique c'est quoi ces
des forces physiques supplémentaires
adverse qui viennent se mêler de la
partie
c'est rajouter de l'énergie dans le
système climatique et donc ça veut dire
que on a des forces adverses
déstabilisation du système qui vient
s'opposer à ce qu'on souhaiterait qu'il
fasse mais face à de l'énergie
nous aussi on peut mettre en oeuvre de
l'énergie
donc dans un premier temps tant qu'on a
plein d'énergie on peut faire face la
déstabilisation climatique nous mêmes en
mettant en oeuvre plus de moyens alors
quelques exemples on a un shove qu'ils
aient tenté de sortir plus ou moins de
son lit et bien avec des pelleteuses en
creux un bassin de rétention à la bombe
et le fleuve sans moins facilement de
son lit mais les pelleteuses ont besoin
d'énergie fossile les maisons sont trop
souvent inondée qu'à cela ne tienne on
les monte tout sur pilotis ou on les
détruit en construit d'autres ça suppose
d'avoir un énergies fossiles ça ne
pousse plus ici mais ça continue à
pousser là c'est pas grave on peut
transporter la nourriture de là où ça ne
pousse pas vers là où ça pousse
et on fait ça avec l'inde énergies
fossiles l'eau si on commence à monter
c'est pas très grave je vais des digues
du béton des tractopelles etc
voilà donc d'une manière générale et
puis d'énergies fossiles permettent
d'alimenter des systèmes de
communication qui permettent de bien se
coordonner et de coordonnées rapidement
l'énergie fossile permet de faire
tourner plus vite les industries pour
reconstruire ce qui a été détruit
donc aujourd'hui dans le monde des
industries fossiles quand il ya un
tremblement de terre à kobe ça détruit
du pib au moment où ça arrive mais ça en
recréant encore plus quand il faut tout
reconstruire
donc dans dans le monde de l'abondance
et en particulier de l'abondance
énergétique avoir un début de changement
climatique le grand paradoxe c'est que
c'est même pas peur
et en plus ça fait du pib parce que
casser et reconstruire sa fait du pays d
box est très paradoxal
voilà c'est le paradoxe du pib bien
connu aussi sur les accidents de la
route les tremblements de terre et c'est
là où la chose va commencer à devenir un
peu plus sportive
c'est quand le changement climatique va
continuer à s'amplifier parce qu'il va
continuer à s'amplifier pendant des
milliers d'années alors que les énergies
fossiles va commencer à décroître
alors pourquoi est-ce que l'énergie
fossile va s'amplifier pendant des
milliers d'années le changement
climatique va s'amplifier pendant des
milliers d'années
parce que le temps de résidence d'un
surplus de co2 dans l'atmosphère dont
quand on crée un surplus de co2 dans
l'atmosphère
son temps de résidence et de l'ordre du
millier d'années donc en fait il faut
attendre pour être précis dix mille ans
pour que le surplus de co2 concret
aujourd'hui et qu'on a déjà créé
finissent par ces purées en quasi
totalité
une fois qu'on voit à ce genre de
constantes de temps on comprend donc que
le changement climatique est quelque
chose qui ne peut qu'augmenter au cours
des temps historiques pour les quelques
siècles ou quelques milliers d'années
qu'il reste aux hommes à vivre
je partis quand on est pas sûr que
quelle que soit la région ça va durer
beaucoup plus longtemps
eh bien on va avoir un climat qui va
continuer à s'amplifier
alors quelques exemples aujourd'hui on
est raisonnablement sur leur quand je
dis on c'est la communauté scientifique
compétente que si on dépasse les 2
degrés et on est évidemment partie pour
les dépasser nous allons mettre en route
la déstabilisation de la calotte
antarctique de l'ouest la calotte
antarctique de l'ouest c'est cette
partie de la calotte antarctique qui se
trouve sous le chiffre a soulginé qui
pointe vers le chili et la terre de feu
et cette calotte glaciaire elle est
située sur un socle rocheux qui est pour
partie sous marins pour partie en pente
et elle est stabilisée cette calotte par
des grands arcs boutants de glace
flottante qui se situe sur les deux
maires qui sépare cette partie de
l'antarctique du reste du continent
antarctique beaucoup plus massif cette
calotte elles pourraient être
déstabilisés par un début de
réchauffement climatique
et une fois que la déstabilisation est
enclenchée il ya des processus
d'amplification ce qu'on appelle des
rétroactions positives qui font que la
fonte et la désagrégation ne s'arrête
plus donc une fois que ça a commencé
ça ne s'arrête plus jusqu'à la prochaine
entrée en glaciation si elle arrive un
jour et la désagrégation et la fonte de
cette calotte ses six mètres dos en plus
pour l'océan mondial et donc il ya une
publication qui est paru en 2007 dans
nature qui dit que au dessus de 2 degrés
encore une fois on est parti pour
franchir allègrement et bien cette
calotte sera déstabilisé et donc l'océan
montera de quelques mètres en quelques
siècles à cause de la désagrégation de
cette calotte
on a le même problème sur le groenland
qui est parti pour fondre en partie ou
en totalité dans les siècles qui
viennent et plus la dilatation de l'eau
de mer donc on voit par exemple sur le
millier d'années qui vient
éventuellement les milliers d'années qui
viennent l'océan va continuer à répondre
à la perturbation qu'on a déjà fait dans
l'atmosphère de façon inexorable
voilà donc c'est donc les effets du
changement climatique vont s'amplifier
dans un certain nombre de domaines
quoi qu'on fasse à partir de maintenant
est alors pour en revenir à la question
de départ
il est bien évident que plus
l'approvisionnement énergétique fossile
baisse vite parce qu'on a une contrainte
de stock et - la perturbation à gérer
sera ample mais par contre plus nous
serons démunis en termes de moyens pour
y faire face donc en gros on est dans
une équation ou si le pic fossiles
arrive rapidement
on a des charges qui baissent mais des
produits ti baisse et c'est difficile de
savoir si c'est une meilleure affaire
que si le pic arriver un peu plus tard
avec des charges qui augmentent mais des
produits qui augmentent donc c'est très
difficile pour conclure de répondre à
cette question
par contre ce qui est certain c'est que
on peut en tirer l'option sans regret
l'option sans regret c'est de consacrer
ce qui nous reste d'énergie fossile
extractible est utilisable
aujourd'hui pour se mettre le plus vite
possible en ordre de bataille pour être
capable de gérer un changement
climatique qui va s'amplifier et deux
pour être capables de s'affranchir le
plus vite possible des combustibles
fossiles en question dit autrement si
les combustibles fossiles qui reste je
les utilise plus tôt pour faire des
pompes à chaleur des centrales
nucléaires des éoliennes de la laine de
verre et des trains c'est mieux que si
je les utilise pour continuer à faire
voler des avions
voilà c'est ça le saas est absolument
certain quelle que soit l'option qu'on
puisse prendre sur la date à laquelle il
y aura le pic le pic fossiles alors la
question suivante est due à
[Musique]
monsieur à maulde à quelle orientation
de carrière concerne nous
conseillez-vous pardon aux jeunes
diplômés qui souhaitent avoir le maximum
d'impact sur la mise en place de la
transition écologique et bien la réponse
que je n'en sais rien un tout petit peu
plus sérieux quand même
pour être capable d'influer sur le
système cantonné dans une entreprise où
quand on est dans une administration
parce que finalement c'est ça une
orientation de carrière où on souhaite
il ya quelque chose il faut réunir de
deux caractéristiques il faut connaître
le métier de l'entreprise dans laquelle
on est parce que si on ne connaît pas le
métier de l'entreprise on ne sait pas ce
qu'elle peut faire d'utile ou de
nuisibles est par ailleurs en interne on
n'a pas de légitimité pour parler aux
autres personnes qui y travaillent et
essayer de les convaincre
il faut savoir qu'une entreprise s'est
malheureusement pas quelque chose
d'homogène c'est une communauté de
personnes
ces gens sondage dider de sexe ni
d'ailleurs même si l'or est limité à
deux ils sont deux fonctions diverses
ils sont éventuellement d'origines
culturelles et d'origine nationale
diverses et donc faire fonctionner une
entreprise sait faire fonctionner un
attelage qui n'est pas nécessairement en
fait qui n'est jamais totalement
homogène même dans la 2 modeste
entreprise puisque je pilote et copilote
ils sont deux chiffres project d'une
part et carbone4 de l'autre c'est à dire
on va dire 45 personnes et dix de chaque
côté les gens ne sont pas homogènes
c'est probable qu'ils votent pas de la
même façon c'est probable que ils n'ont
pas les mêmes goûts les vins de couleurs
donc pour être capable de faire bouger
les choses dans une entreprise il faut
être capable de faire de la pédagogie
interne et pour faire de la pédagogie
interne
il faut à la fois avoir le respect de
ceux qui font des choses opérationnel
donc il faut être capable de parler de
leur métier et il faut avoir une idée
des idées concrètes sur ce que
l'entreprise peut faire de différent et
pour les pour réunir ces deux
caractéristiques là il faut connaître le
métier de l'entreprise
et malheureusement c'est pour ça qu'on
appelle un contenu les gens ont
l'expérience quand on rentre dans une
entreprise on connaît pas son équipe là
la deuxième chose qu'il faut avoir
et alors ça j'ai envie de dire c'est
l'option sans regret pour les jeunes
c'est qu'il faut comprendre de quel
problème on parle donc là quelle que
soit la façon de se sentir utile dans
une entreprise ou dans une
administration ou dans une association
pour faire avancer le schmilblick
de toute façon c'est pas du temps de
perdu d'avoir bien compris de quoi on
parle
en ce qui concerne le problème parce que
très souvent vous allez en plus trouver
dans les entreprises des gens qui n'ont
pas envie de changer la manière dont il
fonctionne parce qu'on a tous un côté un
peu flemmard
et si on peut procrastiner faire ça
donne un c'est quand même mieux
et donc il va falloir être capable de
bien argumentée sur le problème à
traiter pour résister aux premiers
objections qui vont vous arrivez qui
seront qu'il ya de très bonnes raisons
de ne pas changer ce qu'on est en train
de faire donc ce donc là l'option sans
regrets quand on a envie de s'investir
plus tard entre guillemets général c'est
ça la caractéristique de la jeunesse sur
laquelle j'en connais une autre c'est se
croire invincible éternelle mais si on
prend la jeunesse comme étant vraiment
l'âge de ses artères
et bien pour quelque part faire quelque
chose d'utile
il faut de toute façon avoir bien
compris le problème alors j'en profite
pour faire un peu de pub bien comprendre
le problème aujourd'hui dans
l'enseignement secondaire au supérieur
c'est très difficile parce que
l'enseignement sur les sujets comporte
savoir l'énergie le climat reste des
enseignements qui sont parcellaires si
l'intro pion aux chiffres project on est
en train en ce moment de faire un
inventaire sur ce qui se passe dans
l'enseignement supérieur donc on a
démarré un projet qui m'a sup
et ce projet vise notamment à
inventorier dans 36 établissements
d'enseignement supérieur et qui sont
alors je suis désolé de dire ça qui
atterrissent et quelques poils qui sont
représentatifs de ceux qui forme les
futures classes supérieures coutume
d'appeler les dirigeants
on va regarder dans cet établissement qu
est ce qu on leur apprend ou qu'est-ce
qu'on ne la reprends pas aujourd'hui en
matière d'énergie et de climat donc d'en
faire un recensement parce que c'est
évident que la première des choses sur
laquelle on peut agir c'est ce qu'on
apprend aux jeunes qui devront demain de
gré ou de force
gérer une partie du problème une fois
que on imagine que on est à peu près
formé sur le problème ce qui aujourd'hui
se fait beaucoup par formation extra
professionnelles et un tout petit peu
dans le cadre de l'enseignement ou de la
formation continue une parenthèse
moi j'ai appris ce que je sais sur
l'énergie et le climat essentiellement
en dehors de mon métier en dehors de
tout système éducatif c'est à dire qu'un
jour j'ai décidé que j'avais un peu de
temps j'allais lire le rapport du giec
l'élu j'ai passé beaucoup beaucoup de
temps en fait à l'époque où je
construisais mon site internet à poser
des tas de questions à droite et à
gauche a des tas de gens qui à l'époque
aussi avec temps de me répondre
qui aujourd'hui n'est pas toujours le
cas et c'est exactement comme ça que
j'ai appris il ya il ya toujours pas à
ma connaissance aujourd'hui
d'enseignement un peu long et un peu
structuré qui correspondent à l'ensemble
de ce que j'ai dû ingurgiter à l'époque
voilà le savez c'est évident que c'est
un vrai besoin mais donc le pour en
revenir à ce que disait une fois qu'on
sait quelque chose donc les entreprises
il faut y rentrer et il faut apprendre
leur métier alors il ya une voie
intermédiaire et alors que personne ne
se méprenne c'est pas de la pub je suis
en train de faire pour mon entreprise il
ya une voie intermédiaire qu'il
conseille le conseil et tu as carbone 4
on recrute sur des jeunes par exemple
alors c'est des jeunes qui correspondent
à la condition préalable que j'ai exposé
tout à l'heure c'est dire que c'est des
gens qui savent compter que c'est sinon
les ingénieurs etc des gens qui de
préférence connaissent déjà un peu le
problème dont on parle donc c'est des
gens qui par 36 par par goût
ont eu l'occasion de se former sur les
sujets contracte mais c'est une voie
intermédiaire parce que dans ces
domaines là on embauche beaucoup de
jeunes on s'est éteint est un domaine
économique dans lequel on n'embauche pas
mal de jeunes et à ce moment ces jeunes
là ils sont formés non pas aux métiers
des entreprises pour lesquelles on
travaille mais ils sont formés à être
capable de faire une partie du travail
quand une entreprise nous pose une
question étant entendu que dans la boîte
de conseil
il ya aussi d'autres personnes plus
expérimentées qui elles connaissent le
métier de l'entreprise qui nous pose la
question et qui donc sont capables
d'apporter le complément
voilà donc la voile après je ne peux
parler que de ce que je connais
l'engagement associatif qui est
également une voix pour des gens qui ont
envie de sauver le monde est en fait une
voix qui aujourd'hui est numériquement
assez peu nombreuses c'est à dire que
les associations embauchent peu parce
que c'est des toutes petites entités
je vais en prendre une que je connais
très bien et qui est la fondation pour
la nature et l'homme c'est trente
personnes de chic project c'est six
salariés à temps plein le vvf doit être
à 80 et je pense que c'est la plus
grosse ong environnementales françaises
donc c'est des tout petits effectifs par
rapport aux gens qui ne serait ce que
dans le conseil s'occupe de questions
qui sont liées au climat est où là les
effectifs en france doivent déjà se
mesurer en quelques milliers donc sans
problème en quelques milliers si on
rajoute les gens qui sont dans chez les
clients et dans les collectivités
locales
voilà donc c'est quand même des
effectifs qui sont plus significatifs et
pour finir selon ce long paragraphe
s'écarquillent un côté très frustrant
quand on veut s'engager parce que pour
faire bouger les lignes faut à la fois
connaître le problème et il faut
connaître le métier de l'entité qui vous
emploient ou de l'entité pour laquelle
vous travaillez
en vrai dans le monde associatif où il
faut connaître le fonctionnement des
entités qu'on a en face de soi
e
alors une question courte si
l'effondrement est inévitable pour que
ne serait-il pas souhaitable de
provoquer plus tôt non il ya beaucoup de
masochiste qui sont en train de regarder
mais enfin alors non non sauf que je
vais prendre un tout petit parallèle si
il est inévitable de faire sa
déclaration d'impôts
il vaut mieux la faire dans les délais
plus toqué pas dans les délais parce que
à ce moment là on l'a su qu'on finira
par le faire de toute façon contraints
j'ai envie de dire et en plus cela
coûtera beaucoup plus cher
donc si il ya un vrai bénéfice à ce que
la peine soit subie plus tôt
à ce moment il vaut mieux que la peine
arrive plutôt du reste tous le
militantisme en faveur de il faut
s'occuper du problème avant que le
problème ne s'occupe de nous ils
relèvent de cette logique c'est à dire
il relève du fait qu' il vaut mieux
provoquer le problème entre guillemets
plutôt ce à condition que le problème
soit contenu si on provoque plus tôt
maintenant si on parle d'effondrement
quelque part ça veut dire que de toute
façon le truc se mettre hors de contrôle
et à ce moment ci le truc se met à être
hors de contrôle j'imagine que personne
n'est vraiment précis que ça arrive le
plus tôt possible
enfin en tout cas moi pas trop on va
revenir un tout petit peu sur les
questions de pics de pétrole et qui me
plaisait bien
ah oui pourquoi est-ce que la contrainte
énergétique ne voit pas enfin ne se
traduit pas par un prix c'est une
excellente question et ça c'est une
question qu'on me pose assez souvent en
particulier dans le monde économique
donc dans le monde économique il ya très
souvent la question qui est si on manque
de quelque chose est bien très
logiquement on devrait voir ce manque
dans le fait que le prix augmente
alors c'est vrai sauf que c'est faux la
partie qui est vrai c'est que quand le
pétrole qui est effectivement une
commodité vendus sur un marché voit la
quantité qui est physiquement accessible
diminué à ce moment on se met
effectivement à avoir transitoirement un
prix qui augmentent alors ce transitoire
c'est un an deux ans trois ans
d'ailleurs qu'on a ce qu'on appelle un
choc après le choc
on peut continuer à manquer de pétrole
physiquement et pourtant le prix se
casse la figure
alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire que
l'on manque de pétrole ça veut dire
qu'il n'y en a toujours pas assez pour
que l'économie revienne à son état
précédent
je répète pour ceux d'entre vous qui ne
le savait pas déjà que le fait de
manquer pendant que l'économie voit le
manque de pétrole à travers une baisse
du pib parce que quand on manque de
pétrole en fait ça veut dire que la
quantité de machines qui fonctionnent au
pétrole devient moins importantes chaque
machine fonctionne - où il ya moins de
machines qui fonctionnent les machines
qui fonctionnent au pétrole sont pour
beaucoup des machines à déplacer des
personnes et des marchandises
c'est à dire les machines qui permettent
l'interconnexion de toutes les unités
productives du système mondial et donc
si on a moins de pétrole s'est moins
bien interconnectés et même si les
unités locales peuvent produire on peut
plus assurer la communication aussi bien
entre unité et donc la production
globale baisse parce qu'il n'ya pas un
système économique aujourd'hui il ya pas
une chaîne d'approvisionnement ce que
les anglo saxons pompeusement supply
chain il n'y a pas une chaîne de cette
nature qui peut fonctionner aujourd'hui
sans moyen de transport est dit
autrement sans camion sans bateau et
plus marginalement sans avion et il n'y
a pas un système une entreprise de
grande taille qui peut fonctionner sans
voiture donc le 6 à moins de pétrole
dans un premier temps comme c'est une
commodité vendus sur les marchés
genevoise son prix qui augmentent mais
dans un deuxième temps comme j'en ai
physiquement pas assez pour faire
fonctionner toutes les machines
la production se casse la figure le pib
baisse et si le pib baisse comme la
preuve comme le pib
c'est la valeur de la production mais
c'est aussi la somme des revenus par
construction et bien les revenus des
gens baissent
et si les revenus des jambes s1 et ben
ils vont avoir un peu moins envie
d'acheter du pétrole et donc à ce moment
même s'il y en a pas plus à offrir le
prix du pétrole baissent
donc le et il peut baisser ce prix du
pétrole
simplement par effet de baisse du pib et
pas du tout parce que
l'approvisionnement pétrolier est revenu
à la quantité qui était la sienne avant
on a très bien vu ça au moment du
premier choc pétrolier cercle premier
choc pétrolier a correspondu à une
augmentation très violente du prix du
pétrole
alors que l'autre la production mondiale
de pétrole a augmenté de 8% par an il
derrière le choc pétrolier la production
mondiale de pétrole s'est mise a
augmenté de 1% par an en moyenne
et pourtant les prix sont redescendus
donc on avait déjà un stress relatif
c'était stressant relatif ca augmenter
moins vite et pourtant ça n'a pas
conduit le prix du pétrole allaient
retrouver périodiquement les niveaux de
prix du choc pétrolier il s'est passé
autre chose
en fait ce qui s'est passé dans ma
vision du monde c'est la création de la
dette mais c'est plus on expliqué et
puis on a eu un deuxième choc pétrolier
en 2005 donc en 2005 c'est pas un
changement de dérives et c'est de
nouveau un changement dérivés cercle
bleu pétrole augmenter de 20 % par an en
moyenne et il sait biz augmenté 0 or
chez laurie la production mondiale de
pétrole stagne et or chez lloyd et par
sens donc sables bitumineux là plutôt
tendance à légèrement s'éroder ce qui
est la cause du déclin de
l'approvisionnement pétrolier européen à
partir de 2006 soit dit en passant
la france est en concurrence avec les
pays émergents qui en prennent une part
plus importante par le jeu de mécanismes
économiques que j'ai pas encore compris
donc ça je n'ai pas d'explication à
proposer je sais juste qu'ils en
prennent une part plus importante et
donc du coup si l'approvisionnement
mondial est stable et bien les pays ocde
en près de moi c'est valable même pour
les états unis dont l'approvisionnement
énergétique en temps contraction depuis
le milieu des années 2000 comme comme
chez
alors une fois que j'ai dit ça on
comprend bien que la pénurie
je le redis elle peut s'appliquer de
manière physique sans que pour autant ça
se traduise dans les prix alors
maintenant question pourquoi ça
s'applique de manière physique à la
réponse c'est que le pétrole doit
nécessairement passer par un pic et donc
ça peut aussi bien être maintenant ça
c'est la réponse que peu à peu bête
la réponse plus complète et elle est en
lien avec une autre question qui a été
posée sur le sur le peak oil c'est à
dire c'est quoi le sait quand la date du
pic oil la la la date du peak oil
c'est la date à laquelle
l'approvisionnement pétrolier mondial
passera par un maximum absolu c'est à
dire qu'il passera par le plus haut
qu'il atteindra jamais et puis derrière
il n'y retournera plus jamais jamais
jamais comment est-ce qu'on peut essayer
de dire à quel moment cela ça arrivera
eh bien on peut essayer de le dire en
connaissant approximativement la
quantité totale de pétrole qu'on peut
extraire du sol
alors cette quantité totale de pétrole
qu'on peut extraire du sol sa
connaissance augmente nécessairement
avec le temps ça augmente nécessairement
avec le temps parce que le parce que
avec le temps on a exploré
regardez farfouiller dans de plus en
plus d'endroits donc la géologie et de
mieux en mieux connus à la surface de la
planète
il ya de plus en plus d'endroits où il
ya eu de la sismique et des forages
d'exploration forages d'exploration dont
je rappelle qu'aujourd'hui en a qu'un
sursis ce qui est conclusive c'est à
dire que quand on se dit il ya peut-être
du pétrole là et on va faire un forage
d'exploration en gros c'est un sur six
qui dit oui il ya bien des pétroles met
donc on connaît de mieux en mieux la
géologie mondiale et donc on a une idée
on étend la communauté des pétroliers
meilleur avec le temps de la quantité
totale qui peut être extraite alors une
fois qu'on sait que la quantité totale
elle est extraite c'est les
mathématiques qui s'appliquent les
mathématiques vous disent que quand tu
accumules dans le temps il est limité à
une valeur qui est donné entre moins
affiliées plus l'infini c'est à dire
encore entre le début des temps et la
nuit des temps on va dire entre la nuit
des temps et la fin des temps comment
eh bien les mathématiques vous
permettent de donner approximativement
la date du maximum à une condition qui
est importante c'est que la courbe
d'extraction elle soit alors pas
totalement symétrique mais à peu près
symétrique
c'est à dire que la forme de la montée
en puissance de la production mondiale
soit pas très différente de la vitesse
de décrue à ce moment on donne à peu
près une date au maximum il ya quelque
chose qui vient compliquer l'équation
dans le dans les périodes récentes c'est
que les statistiques sur le pétrole ont
tendance à compter avec le temps des
choses qui deviennent un peu différente
il ya 40 ans on extrayait de terre
surtout du pétrole quand on trouvait du
gaz s'était pas intéressant on s'en
occupait pas quand on trouvait du gaz
dissous dans le pétrole ont laissé
partir dans l'atmosphère sans le
récupérer et donc ce qui finissait par
rentrer dans les pipelines en entrée des
raffineries
là on commence à raconter c'était
vraiment du pétrole
aujourd'hui on extrait de plus en plus
de gaz est avec le gaz on extrait des
des chaînes carbonées qui vont de ces
deux c'est à dire les thann
ces 2 h 6 jusqu'à assez vite l'octane
qui sont pas vraiment du pétrole qui
sont plus de gaz puisque le gaz c'est
juste le méthane ch4 et que selon les
gens qui font les statistiques et
surtout selon le tuyau dans lequel ça
rentre au moment où cet extrait on va
compter comme étant du pétrole ou pas
alors il ya une catégorie qu'on compte
toujours avec le pétrole qu'on appelle
les condensats les condensats c'est ce
qui sort avec le gaz c'est 5 à ses huit
sacs on danse en tête de puits et ça
c'est directement envoyé avec le pétrole
dans les raffineries s'est comptée comme
du pétrole et on peut raisonnablement
dire que c'en est presque
et puis vous avez également ce qu'on
appelle les liquides de gaz c2 c3 c4 qui
sont donc pour ceux qui connaissent et
anne propane butane et qui eux qu'on
danse quand on met le gascon a extrait
du gisement à très basse température
c'est à ce moment là qui condense c'est
pour ça qu'on les appelle gast plantes
liquid il faut faire passer ça dans une
usine et cela selon les gens qui font
les statistiques ons les comptes avec le
pétrole dont les comptes pas avec eux
pétrole bp par exemple british petroleum
la kiné public son fameux livre
statistiques dp stats
concert avec du pétrole l' agence
internationale pardon l'énergie
information agency donc l'agencé
américaine d'information sur l'énergie
ne compte pas ça avec le pétrole
concert de manière séparée donc c'est ça
peut donner lieu selon con mais c'est g
l dans le pétrole ou pas dans le pétrole
ça déforme les statistiques et ça
déforme un peu la date du pic
parce que la production de gaz
continuera à croître après que la
production de pétrole stricto sensu et
commencer à décroître
alors après ces longues digressions la
fourchette de dates que j'ai vu passer
sur le pic de production va de 2006 pour
la production du pétrole conventionnel
stricto sensu
c'est à dire sans tenir compte ni des
liquides de gaz ni d'état recense donc
des sables bitumineux ni du challenge
mais qui fait quand même cinq millions
de barils jour aujourd'hui c'est quand
même pas rien donc si on compte pas à
ces trois trucs là c'est 2006-10 d'aucun
et la date la plus lointaine que j'ai vu
passer en provenance de milieux à peu
près crédible doit être aujourd'hui 2030
voilà peut-être 2040
la majeure partie des gens s'accordent
sur le fait que 2020 2030
normalement on y est alors dans les
signes avant coureurs il ya le fait que
vous avez un certain nombre de patrons
de majors pétrolières récemment mais
c'est très difficile de savoir si c'est
un signal caché envoyé à certains pays
ou avec lesquelles ils pourraient faire
des affaires au gouvernement pour éviter
des impôts au alors actionné avec leurs
actionnaires pour changer stratégie
c'est très difficile de savoir à qui
sait vraiment destiné mais il ya un
certain nom de major de patron de
patrons de majors pétrolières pardon qui
ont récemment dit que il y avait ce qui
est de commencer à y avoir un vrai
problème à partir de 2020
de toute façon si j'en reviens au début
de cette digression sur
l'approvisionnement européen en europe
mon pronostic économique donc c'est que
la contraction de l'approvisionnement
pétrolier est parti en route donc on est
passé par un maximum secondaire le
premier était au moment des chocs
pétroliers de l'approvisionnement en
pétrole en europe et en 2006 depuis sa
décline gentiment entre 2014 et 2017
c'est remonté à cause du boom du chayla
est là mais qui est en train de se
passer
lalush et lloyd est en train de
plafonner à quelque chose qui est à peu
près stable
et comme le reste de la production dans
le monde s'est fait de gros projets ou
avec le prix bas du pétrole il ya eu peu
d'investissements un pronostic
raisonnable qu'on peut faire c'est que
ça devrait arrêter de monter voir
commencer à baisser dans les années à
venir est en tout cas en europe
ça va se remettre à baisser dans les
années à venir ça c'est peut-être
l'année prochaine
ça me paraît à peu près évident ce qui
signifie que en europe les conditions
qui ont prévalu à la crise de 2008 sont
en train de se remettre en place à
nouveau
c'est à dire 1 a provoqué un
approvisionnement énergétique qui va se
contracter donc une production réelle
qui va se contracter
face à une dette qui est à des records
historiques
adro voilà donc la date du pic mondial
pour nous autres européens
elle va être précédée de toute façon par
le retour dans les deux ans qui viennent
dans nuit nier au chantage de
l'approvisionnement et ça va faire
monter c'est un peu en lien avec la
question précédente sur l'effondrement
ça va faire monter la détresse
économique et donc le populisme et je
suis pas sûr qu'on soit très pressé de
voir d instabilité politique majeur se
développer en europe car à ce moment là
la chose sur laquelle je suis
raisonnablement prêt à parier beaucoup
d'argent c'est que les pouvoirs en place
n'attribue rompt pas les problèmes parce
que je suis en train d'évoquer mais
attribueront les problèmes à tout un tas
d'autres causes et à tout un tas
d'autres boucs émissaires et donc le
remède à porter ne réglera pas
problème voir le banquier alors
[Musique]
seriez-vous favorable un rationnement
d'énergie fossile la réponse est oui
la taxe carbone c'est exactement ça la
taxe carbone c'est un rationnement des
énergies fossiles
il ya deux manières ou directement trois
manières de rationner les énergies
fossiles
il ya une manière qui est par les prix
donc ça c'est le principe de la taxe
carbone je fais monter les prix et puis
du coup les gens sont obligés d'en
consommer un peu moins alors l'argument
en faveur de ce truc là c'est que c'est
efficace si on fait monter suffisamment
les prix l'argument en défaveur de ce
truc là c'est que ça n'est pas ciblé dit
autrement les pauvres et les riches sont
obligées de s'adapter tous les deux de
manière égale j'ai envie de dire
et comme les riches ont plus de moyens
eh bien ils s'adaptent plus facilement
donc les gens qui sont pas riches disent
c'est pas juste parce que les riches
parce qu'ils sont riches ont plus de
facilité alors je rappelle que les
riches en plus de facilités parce qu'ils
sont riches
quels que soient les problèmes à régler
ça s'est produit au carbone mais à un
moment il va bien falloir contraindre la
masse c'est-à-dire aussi entre
guillemets les pauvres c'est à dire les
modestes et les classes moyennes
il va bien falloir les contraindre aussi
si ça doit concerner tout le monde alors
après on peut être on peut faire un
rationnement égalitaire mais qui est pas
nécessairement plus malin c'est à dire
qu'on dit mme à chacun a le droit a par
exemple 200 litres de pétrole dans
l'année
le problème que ça ne règle pas c'est
qu'une partie du pétrole consommé
mutualisés par exemple dans les
centrales électriques on consomme un peu
de pétrole
si je ne peux 200 litres de pétrole à
chaque français comment est-ce que je
gère celui des centrales électriques
est ce que chacun doit reverser un peu
de pétrole pour avoir de l'électricité
est ce que je dis non non je mutualisent
donc en fait c'est 200 litres il y en a
une petite partie que je donne aux
producteurs d'électricité au fuel qui
sont nécessaires pour réguler le réseau
et puis le reste du pétrole je le donne
aux français de manière égalitaire à ce
moment sur quelle base est ce que je
décide que je vais rationner les
centrales à fuel ou par endroits
donc le rationnement égalitaire il n'est
pas nécessairement très simple et alors
rien rationnement ciblées qui est
également quelque chose qui peut faire
pour tous et qui à mon avis est une part
essentielle aujourd'hui du règlement du
problème qui est la réglementation ce
que la réglementation finalement c'est
pas rationnement alors je vais donner un
exemple si peut-être que les plus vieux
qui sont en train de me regarder se
souviennent de l'époque où en france on
avait un impôt sur la détention des
voitures qui s'appelle la vigne est donc
cet impôt c'était un impôt qui étaient
payés chaque année par le propriétaire
d'une voiture et cet impôt était
proportionnel à la puissance de la
voiture donc de fait à sa consommation
c'était ça les chevaux fiscaux ça
servait à payer la vignette et puis le
président de la coop 21 c'est à dire
laurent fabius a dit que c'était pas un
bon impôt donc il l'a supprimée alors
qu'à mon avis était excellente un taux
ont donc imaginons qu'on rejette cet
impôt en service à ce moment ça dissuade
les gens d'acheter des grosses voitures
donc je suis quelqu'un de modeste j'ai
besoin absolument d'une voiture pour
aller au travail et va très bien on va
m'interdire d'acheter une grosse voiture
c'est pas grave j'ai toujours les moyens
en acheter une petite avec la vignette
qui est pas cher et puis je peux faire
encore mieux que ça je peux remettre en
place la vignettes et dans le même temps
je peux mettre une prime à la casse
extrêmement incitative sur le
remplacement d'une voiture à 6 litres
aux 100 par une voiture à 2 litres aux
cent à ce moment qu'est ce que j'ai fait
j'ai rationnés c'est à dire que j'ai
interdit aux gens d'acheter des grosses
voitures en mettant des vignettes qui
sont prohibitives à partir d'un certain
niveau de consommation dont je déprécie
de prix des grosses voitures
donc je tape dans la poche des riches
c'est parfait je favorise l'accès aux
toutes petites voitures par les gens
pour les gens qui ont vraiment besoin
d'avoir une voiture mais par la
réglementation gelé rationne sur le
carburant puisque je suis sûr qu'ils
vont acheter une petite voiture je suis
sûr que j'augmente pas le parc de
voitures parce que c'est une prime à la
casse donc je suis sûr qu'on m'envoie
une voiture à la casse qui consommaient
6 litres en échange d'une voiture qui
consomme un litre et demi donc voilà un
dispositif dans lequel j'ai organisé le
rationnement du pétrole mais si je n'ai
pas dis des bêtises grosses comme moi à
l'instant j'ai essayé d'organiser de
manière intelligente
c'est à dire que c'est un rationnement
qui est socialement supportable et pas
destructif pour les gens qui ont
vraiment besoin d'aller à 20 bornes de
chez eux parce que c'est là qu'ils leur
boulot qu'ils changeront pas facilement
etc etc
et j'ai quand même rassuré le pétrole je
vais donner un autre exemple je peux
décider qu'à partir de maintenant
toute personne qui a une chaudière qui
cassent et qui la remplace doit la
remplacer par une pompe à chaleur
voilà rationnement aussi du gaz et du
pétrole
après il me je peux très bien organisé
ce rationnement en soit en le laissant à
la charge du propriétaire de la
chaudière donc si tu avais prévu de
partir en vacances tu partira pas en
vacances tu vas changer sa chaudière
tu avais prévu d'acheter des pulls des
tirs des soldats ne soient pas faire les
soldes qui va changer sa chaudière
donc je peux très bien dire c'est à la
charge du propriétaire ou bien je peux
considérer que l'enjeu est suffisamment
important pour la collectivité pour que
la collectivité est ça je les recycler
en mai chiffres on favorise certains
d'entre vous ont peut-être déjà entendu
citer qu'eux car plaisir le site a une
fois de plus la france à fin 2017 a déjà
engagé sur son programme éolien et
solaire
121 milliards d'euros avant l'éolien
offshore auxquels on peut rajouter 25
milliards d'euros au titre de l'éolien
offshore
ça fait ça fait quasiment 150 milliards
d'euros eh bien avec ces mêmes 150
milliards d'euros que soit dit en
passant j'ai pris dans la poche des
ménages puisque tout ça est assis sur
des taxes sur l'électricité est financée
par les taxes sur l'électricité et
maintenant les taxes sur le carburant
des ménages j'aurais très bien pu payer
une pompe à chaleur à 15 millions de
foyers c'est à dire à peu près à la
quasi totalité à la totalité des foyers
français chauffer au fioul ça c'est sûr
et aux deux tiers on va dire des foyers
français chauffés au gaz
donc je jeu pour revenir sur mon idée de
rationnement c'est juste pour dire que
organiser un rationnement c'est pas
nécessairement organiser la souffrance
voilà ça peut être une bonne
réglementation
c'est une façon d'organiser un
rationnement et c'est une façon qui peut
être parfaitement pertinente et légitime
de le faire voilà donc le mot en tant
que tel c'est peur parce que ça renvoie
optique est pas de la dernière guerre
le ticket de peindre la dernière guerre
c'était une façon d'organiser le
rationnement mais y en a plein d'autres
et je le redis la réglementation et en
particulier une façon qui peut être
intelligente si elle est bien pensée de
d'organiser le rationnement
quelqu'un me dit la pompe à chaleur
c'est hors de prix par rapport à une
chaudière à condensation à gaz oui
absolument mais si la collectivité la
paye pour le ménage c'est plus hors de
prix c'est gratuit donc c'est juste une
affaire de la façon dont le système
s'organise par ailleurs aujourd'hui
c'est très cher parce que c'est vendu en
toute petite série donc les
installateurs sont des marges
conséquentes parce qu'ils sont tous
assurent quelque part ils veulent être
sûrs de ne pas perdre leur chemise s'ils
sont obligés de regarder cinq fois parce
qu'ils ont mal réglé le truc on n'a pas
de grandes séries sur la production
industrielle donc ça nous coûte cher
et enfin il ya une externalité majeur à
partir du moment où on met en place des
pompes à chaleur c'est on évite
d'importer le pétrole qui sert au fioul
et le gaz et donc ça c'est une école
juillet toute économie d'importation et
du pib concret dans le pays donc il ya
moyen de recirculer cet argent de façon
intelligente donc macroéconomique mans
j'ai intérêt à remplacer toutes les
chaudières au fioul et toutes les
chaudières au gaz par des pompes à
chaleur le pays il gagne il faut savoir
que la suède est tellement chauffé par
des pompes à chaleur dans le diffus et
je ne pense pas que les suites wcs est
considérablement plus stupide que nous
et par ailleurs il fait plutôt fut plus
froid qu'en france donc oui si on laisse
le ménage tout prendre à sa charge
ça coûte plus cher maintenant il faut
bien voir que on ne change pas le monde
sans en changer le monde comme aurait
dit du jardin
donc si on veut changer le monde il va
bien falloir que chacun d'entre nous on
change quelque chose dans la façon dont
fonctionne et en particulier s'il faut
qu'on achète des pompes à chaleur ne
plus cher qu'une chaudière à gaz
enfin si on veut régler le problème
volontairement avant l'effondrement
confère le début des interventions
alors j'ai parlé de tout ça j'ai parlé
de tout ça j'ai parlé de tout ça à ton
d'autres sources que la nasa sur le taux
de co2 atmosphérique
ben oui y'a des sources françaises la
nasa n'est pas tout à fait contrainte de
se taire aujourd'hui il ya quand même on
arrête quand même pas une administration
comme ça tron pas essayer de mettre à la
tête de la nasa
quelqu'un qui était soi disant enfin qui
est présenté comme climato sceptiques
alors ce qui est sûr c'est que ça va
avoir un impact sur les budgets
ce qui est sûr aussi c'est que ça se
conduit pas les scientifiques qui
publient à changer leur publication
demain matin ni les appareils qui
fonctionnent en ce moment arrêtée de
fonctionner demain matin donc les
mesures en continu qui sont faites par
les observatoires piloté par la nasa ne
vont pas s'arrêter demain matin mais
maintenant il ya beaucoup d'autres
endroits où on mesure le co2 en continu
donc là c'est la france à une station de
mesure en continu dans les terres
australes je sais plus où exactement
karadeniz je crois et puis à d'autres
pays qui mesure le co2 en continu dans
l'atmosphère on en a plein à droite et à
gauche
donc heureusement on ne dépend plus de
la nasa pour mesurer ce genre de choses
uniquement cela étant mesuré le co2 en
continu aujourd'hui je vais être un peu
taquin c'est utile pour mesurer le co2
c'est devenu inutile pour passer à
l'action c'est à dire que pour passer à
l'action aujourd'hui le problème c'est
plus de mesurer le co2 dont on constate
qu il y monte on connaît les processus à
l'oeuvre et on sait qu'il va continuer à
monter tant qu on émettra plus que ce
que les puits peuvent absorber la vraie
question aujourd'hui c'est passer à
l'action
et alors du coup on peut en tirer une
question supplémentaire qui est est ce
que le fait de voir le co2 montée
conduit les gens à passer à l'action et
malheureusement j'ai peur que non j'ai
peur que non parce que si ça devait être
le cas ça serait déjà visibles c'est à
dire qu'on passerait déjà à l'action
dans les fêtes
j'ai vérifié une statistique qui a peu
que kim a évidemment rendu à peau de
chagrin et que je j'ai posté sur
linkedin
donc j'ai désole encore des gaffes il
n'y a pas plus tard que deux jours où
j'ai remarqué que la fraction
d'électricité non fossiles dans le monde
qui était de 36% en 1985 et de 35 %
aujourd'hui
donc en fait ça fait 30 ans qu'on voit
le co2 monter dans l'atmosphère et même
avant puisque 1958 et ça fait 30 ans que
la proportion d'électricité fossiles
dans la production mondiale est restée
la même
le charbon est resté le même
il est toujours attendu pour cent le
pétrole est descendu le gaz est monté
donc ça fait un peu moins par
kilowattheure mais globalement c'est
c'est négligeable donc le les trois
énergies fossiles qui ont le plus
augmenté les trois énergies pardon non
plus augmenté sur les 15 dernières
années c'est les trois énergies fossiles
charbon pétrole gaz
donc c'est parfait dans l'eau donnant
dans l'autre sens charbon gaz pétrole
donc c'est c'est malheureusement le fait
de voir le co2 monter dans l'atmosphère
n'a pas d'effet discernable alors je
vais aller un cran plus loin et revenir
à la démocratie
j'ai fini par me faire à la conclusion
triste mais malheureusement réaliste que
le climat est au mieux un sous produit
d'une action qui a un but de plus court
terme
donc on s'occupe du climat en chine
parce que les gens ne respire plus dans
les villes à cause des particules on
s'occupe pas du climat en chine parce
que ça va désertifier d'amazonie les
chinois ne se préoccupe pas plus que
nous de ce problème là on s'occupe du
climat on va dire dans un pays quand les
effets du changement climatique commence
à devenir visibles mais à ce moment il
est trop tard est ce qu'il faut pour
qu'on s'occupe correctement du climat
c'est que les acteurs qui ont un intérêt
de court terme à ce qu'on s'en occupe
notamment parce que ils vendent quelque
chose qui est utile
comprennent ou con
place pour une raison qui n'est pas
nécessairement celle du climat alors je
prendre un cas de figure qui est notre
cher pays
notre cher pays importe la totalité de
ses combustibles fossiles donc à chaque
fois que je suis capable de rendre un
service au pays
en important moins de combustibles
fossiles de rendre le même service
eh bien j'ai amélioré la balance
commerciale et de ce fait j'ai créé de
l'emploi en france
donc voilà une bonne raison de s'occuper
du climat c'est qu'à chaque fois que je
baisse les importations de combustibles
fossiles
je crée de l'emploi a service constant
donc si je remplace des voitures assez
vite par des voitures à 2 litres vendus
au même prix parce qu'elles sont plus
sophistiqués plus cher plus légère en
matériaux piste etc
et bien pas nécessairement aussi lourde
et aussi puissant mais quand même vendu
au même prix
eh bien je crée de l'emploi en france
donc
or la création d'emplois ça c'est un
prennent de court terme dans toutes les
démocraties c'est un trend court terme
donc je peux voir l'effet de court terme
comme étant suffisant pour faire ce qui
va par ailleurs être pertinent sur le
long terme car on pourrait le dire mais
c'est vrai de tous les trucs qui créent
de l'emploi
certes mais si on se soucie du climat ce
qu'il faut c'est chercher par quelle
mesure commence et qui ont un bénéfice
de court terme et pas juste le fait que
ce soit bon pour le climat autre exemple
passer d'une centrale à charbon à soi un
barrage soit une centrale nucléaire soit
des éoliennes
eh bien ça diminue la quantité de
particules fines qui se baladent dans
l'atmosphère ça c'est un bénéfice de
court terme donc sur les gens peuvent y
être sensible si vous changez des
voitures par des vélos en ville un
certain nombre de gens peuvent être
sensible au fait que c'est plus sympa de
se balader à pied là où il n'ya pas les
voitures et là où il ya que des vélos
etc etc
donc en fait ce qu'il faut à chaque fois
qu'on a envie de faire progresser la
cause climatique c'est de se pencher sur
le bénéfice de court terme qui va avec
ce qu'on cherche à défendre et chercher
à traire à soit les gens qui vont en
bénéficier
voilà c'est comme ça que et dans le
domaine des eaux vénère pour être un
tout petit peu taquin en fait c'est dans
l'autre sens que ça s'est passé c'est à
dire que quand on a commencé à dire il
faut faire des nerfs électrique et soit
dit en passant c'est est sous la
pression des allemands et c'était
surtout pour des raisons
amphi nucléaire s'était pas tellement
pour des raisons climatiques à cette
époque là à ce moment un certain nombre
de financiers se sont rendus compte que
investir dans les énergies renouvelables
ou le tarif d'achat garanti sur 20 ans
et où les rendement sur capitaux
investis sont très confortables
le solaire à ses débuts c'était 15 % et
même encore aujourd'hui le solaire et
l'éolien en balade à 6% quand les taux
réels sont à zéro c'est beau aussi bien
pour des revenus garantis et bien à ce
moment là les gens qui ont investi dans
ses nerfs ont eu tendance à devenir des
militants du climat par un processus
très naturel chez l'homme qui et quand
quelque chose est intéressant pour lui à
court terme
il a tendance à dire du bien des causes
profondes qui permettent à ce truc là de
se maintenir
voilà donc le je suis parti très loin de
la nasa et du co2 mais quand même c'est
pour dire que de voir le problème
augmenter de façon abstraite avec une
courbe malheureusement ça n'a pas
d'impact direct sur l'action ce qui a un
impact direct sur l'action et de graisse
était une autre question qui était posée
c'est d'arriver à rassembler un groupe
croissant de gens qui ont envie qu'on le
fasse parce que eux en retire par
ailleurs un bénéfice de court terme
c'est soit dit en passant très
exactement la façon dont on a essayé
d'organiser les gens qui financent le
shift c'est à dire qu'on essaye de se
faire financer par des entreprises qui
ont manifestement un bénéfice de court
terme à ce que le problème soit mieux
pris en compte c'est pour ça qu'on est
financé par des gens qui font avancer
des trains qui s'occupe d'électricité
qui pose de la laine de verre ou qui
sait à peu près ça on pourrait avoir des
gens qui vendent des vélos des gens
après les questions de masse financière
mais c'est dans l'esprit c'est
exactement ça donc il ya donc eu ce qui
va pousser les gens à l'action jeudi
c'est l'identification des bénéfices de
court terme de l'action elle-même et
c'est pas malheureusement le fait
d'avoir un indicateur abstrait qui
marque le problème sans compter que la
concentration en co2 de façon très
directe elle ne tue personne pour le
moment les concentration en co2 la
concentration en co2 dans l'atmosphère
n'est pas encore monté à un niveau qui
présenterait
une gêne pour le métabolisme des êtres
vivants
il ya un niveau où ça devient
franchement gênant alors j'ai vu passer
kabyle ppm ça commençait à devenir
gênant pour les mammifères
je ne sais pas je dois dire que ça fait
longtemps que j'ai pas regardé ça ce qui
est sûr c'est que quelques pourcents de
l'air là on commence vraiment à avoir
des effets extrêmement délétère au
niveau auquel on est 400 ppm c'est pas
gênant pour le métabolisme des
mammifères
[Musique]
alors
qu'est-ce que j'ai d'autres jeux prendre
des questions un peu qui arrive est ce
que la transition énergétique est
possible dans le cadre d'une guerre
économique mondiale
la réponse est non donc ça c'est un
autre de mes grands de mes grand credo
c'est que je ne pense pas que on va
pouvoir régler le problème avec le libre
échangisme que nous avons aujourd'hui
pourquoi
en gros le la mondialisation de
l'économie a consisté grâce au pétrole
qui rend le transport extrêmement peu
cher le fait d'avoir le transport peu
cher père mais physiquement de mettre en
compétition
un grand nombre de zones dans le monde
si demain matin on supprimait les
bateaux les avions les camions et les
voir et accessoirement les voitures mais
surtout les trois premiers je ne pourrai
plus mettre en compétition un producteur
de blé français et même un producteur de
blé de la loire avec un producteur de
blé en ukraine
ça serait matériellement pas possible
parce que je ne pourrais tout simplement
pas livrer du blé ukrainien en france en
quantité significative donc le
consommateur français achèterait du blé
français n'auraient pas de marché
mondial du blé et physiquement il
existerait pas tout simplement parce que
je ne serais pas capable de transporter
les marchandises d'un endroit à un autre
donc ce qui a fait la mondialisation
c'est le pétrole c'est le fait d'être
capable de mettre en compétition toutes
les zones du monde les unes avec les
autres
alors une fois que cette compétition
arrive
qu'est-ce qui se passe il se passe que
toute personne qui a un prix de
production inférieurs même en y
rajoutant un coût de transport qui est
devenu ridiculement bas encore une fois
parce que c'est très facile de
transporter en grande quantité parce que
nous avons du pétrole en quantité peut
se mettre en compétition avec quelqu'un
qui était capable de produire à peu près
la même chose ailleurs dans le monde
mais pour des coûts de production plus
élevés et c'est comme ça qu'on se
retrouve en france avec une compétition
entre des poulets industriels français
les poulets industriels brésiliens
quand vous y pensez y quand même faire
manger un poulet en france on va pouvoir
y arriver
gagner ou les m il ya des grains
plus en france compliqué eh bien oui
sauf que non comme le pétrole vaut rien
et bien s'il ya au brésil il ya
quelqu'un qui dit tiens je vais vendre
des poulets en france et des poulets je
vais les vendre moins cher et bien le
jeu économique c'est que pour avoir le
poulet le moins cher possible dans le
supermarché où pour avoir le poulet le
moins cher possible de la cantine de vos
gamins parce que si le prix de la
cantine est trop élevé les parents râle
et bien on a recours à des fournisseurs
pas nécessairement situé à côté de chez
soi admettons maintenant que le
producteur de poulets français il soit à
peu près au même niveau de prix avec les
brésiliens
et puis ils disent moi je vais m'occuper
sérieusement des questions
d'environnement
donc je vais commencer par
m'approvisionner en bio ou en
agriculture raisonnée et cetera où il
n'y a plus la course au rendement parce
que on a arrêté de mettre tout un peuple
truc est de trop travailler le sol et
s'est donc j'accepte de diminuer leur
productivité l'a vécu comme ça du coup
je les payais mes aliments plus cher
donc ont tous les valent plus cher
puis je vais leur donner un peu d'espacé
quand même sympa qu'ils puissent grand
bal et donc je vais faire un encore plus
grand j'ai acheté plus de voyages machin
la plus chère et puis je vais mais
déjections de poulet je vais pas les
laisser comme ça je veux les mettre dans
un méthaniseur faire un peu de gaz avec
ça et puis ça va me permettre de
chauffer la ferme
pourquoi craquent plus cher et donc à
l'arrivée mon poulet qu'à respecter
l'environnement
entre guillemets il se retrouve avec un
prix de revient qui est plus élevé que
le poulet qui n'a pas respecté
l'environnement qui se trouve au brésil
je suis toujours dans le jeu du libre
marché que croyez vous qu'il arriva il
arriva que le poulet français de se
vanter alors ya que deux manières de
faire en sorte qu'il se vende à nouveau
la première c'est de remettre un
rationnement sur le tous les brésiliens
donc je reviens au rationnement tout à
l'heure c'est à dire de faire une
réglementation et donc je dis vous êtes
obligé si vous êtes dans la restauration
collective d'acheter un poulet kara peut
respirer et qui a mangé au moins 20% de
grains bio vous êtes obligés d'acheter
un poulet qui étaient les tel type de
caractéristiques
donc ça veut dire contrôle ça veut dire
du coup des coûts supplémentaires parce
qu'il faut la réglementation et aux
moyens de la faire respecter
mais par contre vous protéger d'une
importation dont vous avez supprimé le
libre échange
vous avez en pratique pris une mesure
protectionniste alors je dis pas que il
faut pas être et donc je pense qu'il
faut être protectionniste il faut être
intelligemment protectionnistes alors là
où je me sens très décontractée c'est
que tous les tenants du libre échangisme
historiques sont en fait des gens qui
ont une vision très asymétriques du
libre échangisme c'est à dire que en
gros ils sont parfaitement pour les
marchés ouverts quand il s'agit
d'exporter beaucoup moins pour les
marchés ouverts quand il s'agit de venir
se faire concurrencer sur leur marché
domestique creuser bien le discours de
tous les gens qui sont les chantres la
mondialisation en général c'est à ça que
ça ressemble
donc le camp pour en revenir à ma
question qui est ce qu'on va réussir
entretenu mais à résoudre ses problèmes
d'environnement dans un contexte de
concurrence libre et non faussée
la réponse est non il faut absolument
revenir à des forces de frottement mise
aux échanges et ses forces de frottement
doivent être d'origine environnementale
alors quelques suggestions qu'on peut
faire
la première c'est de faire des
réglementations le premier c'est que
c'est lourd et que ça se fait par
catégorie de produits parce que je fais
une réglementation sur les poulets puis
j'en fais une sur les carottes qu'ils
ont failli sur les bananes puis j'en
fais une sur le boeuf qu'ils ont failli
sur les zébulons 12 puis j'en fais une
sur le marbre puis j'en fais une sur les
plans de thuya puis enfin bref
puis on fait une sur les tuyaux et les
tuyaux comme ceux ci est chaud comme
cela donc le problème de se protéger des
importations par la réglementation c'est
que c'est très vite usine à gaz donc
c'est très très compliqué à faire c'est
un c'est une idée très intéressante mais
donc je dis pas qu'il faut pas la
poursuivre il faut le faire mais il faut
commencer par des trucs qui sont pas
trop pas trop compliqué manière de faire
c'est la fameuse taxe carbone aux
frontières
donc c'est dire voilà je considère que
une fourchette qui a été fait dans un
pays où on taxe carbone avec des
aciéries et une fourchette qui a été
fait avec de l'acier dans un pays où on
taxe la taxe carbone pardon c'est pas la
même fourchette
l'om c'est vous dire aujourd'hui si
c'est la même fourchette l'organisation
mondiale du commerce ont dit ces deux
fois la même fourchette donc celle sont
comparables sur le marché
donc ya pas de raison de taxes et à
l'importation la deuxième fourchette et
moi je dis va si on devrait taxer à la
forme et à l'importation la fourchette
qui a été produite dans un pays où le
carbone vaut moins cher et où le
producteur est assujettie à des coûts de
production moins cher ce qui doit pas
payer son carbone le même prix à nouveau
idée très intéressante à nouveau
nomenclature douanière extrêmement
compliqué à mettre en place parce que
dans un monde où les produits qui
s'échangent en âge pourquoi cinquante
mille cent mille deux cent mille ça veut
dire qu'il faut créer 200 milles
catégories de produits et en plus alors
la fourchette c'est un peu trop simple
mais si je prends une voiture
j'achète ma voiture venant de corée
corien sont des affreux ils sont passés
de 2 à 6 tonnes de co2 par personne en
l'espace de quelques dizaines d'années
de croissance de la pollution mondiale
par personne ou à peu près eh bien le la
voiture est ce que l a été fait avec de
l'acier coréen va c'est pas sûr si elle
a été faite avec de l'acier chinois
il faut que j'ai le même système en
corée pour inclure la taxe carbone aux
frontières de la chine vers la corée
puis le plastique est ce qu'il a été
fait encore et pas sûr donc si je
commence à prendre des objets composites
non seulement j'ai besoin de ma
nomenclatures douanières mais si je veux
être parfaitement juste j'ai besoin de
savoir si le produit a semblé qui vient
d'un pays a lui même été fait avec des
composants qui viennent d'ailleurs et
qui ont été ou pas assujettis à une taxe
aux frontières
donc l'idée elle est intéressante dans
son concept difficile à mettre en oeuvre
de manière globale en pratique
alors là c'est pareil ça veut pas dire
qu'on peut pas faire on peut en
particulier commencé avec des produits
purs
quand vous faites du ciment de l'acier
de l'éthylène donc un certain nombre de
commodités qui servent qui sont issus de
l'industrie lourde
là vous êtes au tout début de la chaîne
de fabrication dont vous avez eu une ou
deux étapes avant que le produits sont
importés et là on a quelque chose sur
lequel on peut parfaitement asseoir une
taxe qui sera pas trop injuste dans son
principe
on peut encore mettre des protections
avec d'autres d'autres types par exemple
avec de la propriété intellectuelle
alors sur quoi est ce que vous avez de
la propriété intellectuelle en france
sur le fromage
donc nous avons comme vous le savez plus
de fromage que le jour sans la nommer
notre pays et il est interdit de faire
du comté ailleurs que dans le pays où on
fait du compte et non par la comté et
des hobbits du comté et si vous voulez
faire un fromage à pâte cuite ailleurs
que dans la région où on fait dans la
housse et comptait en france ça peut pas
s'appeler comptait donc si vous voulez
vendre du comté en france vous êtes
obligés d'avoir des vaches comme ceux ci
qui mangent du foin fera de l'herbe
plutôt dans un endroit qui est
géographiquement des limites et il ya ça
c'est une réglementation protectrice
alors on pourrait multiplier là aussi
c'est quelque chose qui permet de se
protéger contre les importations
c'est vrai dans le domaine agricole en
particulier donc si on veut augmenter
l'agriculture de qualité c'était une des
propositions du shift portait au moment
du manifeste pour décarbonés l'europe
je vous invite si vous l'avez pas encore
vu à aller ou retourner sur le site du
manifeste du schiste pour décarbonés
l'europe qui est dit carbonneau
europe.org avec un seul e au milieu donc
dit carbo niles you rock poings et vous
verrez les propositions qu'on avait
porté avant l'élection présidentielle il
y en a une qui porte sur l'agriculture
alors il ya un tout petit peu édulcorée
dans son principe mais en gros ce qu'il
faut c'est augmenter tout ce qui est
appellation d'origine protégée
appellation d'origine contrôlée et
labels de qualité de telle sorte que les
conditions qu'on réunit protège la
personne qui va faire bien de la
possibilité d'importer en provenance de
zones où on ferait moins bien sur le
plan environnemental des produits qui en
apparence semblerait équivalent voilà
donc ça ça peut marcher pour laquelle
figure c'est un truc qui est historique
les appellations d'origine contrôlée
protéger et on peut très bien développé
ce système dans d'autres domaines
donc par exemple avoir de l'acier
certifié machin etc et inclure savants
des réglementations donc jeu et j'en
reviens à ce que j'ai tout à l'heure je
pense qu'aujourd'hui malheureusement on
est trop avancée dans le problème
on a 32 ans pour diviser les émissions
par trois pour les deux degrés alors on
n'atteindra pas les deux degrés mais
enfin il faut que demain matin on
commence à faire baisser les émissions
mondiales
il ya juste pour s'auto là dessus et à
ce moment là le problème est trop avancé
donc on n'a plus le temps d'avoir une
taxe qui montent graduellement
c'est malheureusement trop tard
maintenant il faut y aller mon sentiment
par la réglementation qui aura des
effets beaucoup plus rapide que le
système de signal prix et en ce qui
concerne la protection des gens qui font
bien contre la concurrence des gens qui
font mal il faut absolument mettre des
mesures protectrices réglementaire voilà
donc ça pourra être une forme de
protectionnisme ou pas parce que si pour
revenir à l'exemple du début mon
producteur de poulets brésilien décide
que il veut lui aussi donné plein d'
espaces à ses poulets leur faire manger
de la nourriture de bonne qualité être
contrôlés pour tout ça et c est bien il
se mettra à ce moment en compétition
avec le producteur français comme il
devra rajouter le coût de transport
quelque part ça laisse ses chances quand
même un peu aux producteurs français
voilà donc le donc qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire libre libre concurrence et
règlements et solutions oem et alors là
je vais finir par un petit couplet sur
l'europe qui est emblématique de cet
antagonisme dans l'article 3 du traité
alors si tu sais jamais si c'est le
traité sur l'union où le traité
régissant le fonctionnement de l'union
parce que figurez-vous qu'on ad'autres
été pour organiser l'europe mais c'est
l'un des deux l'article 3 dit que
l'europe
elle a pour objet une politique de
croissance c'est écrire et le fait
d'organiser un marché intérieur alors
double double objection votre honneur
pour moi l'europe elle a pour but de
faire la paix pour ça qu'elle a été fait
les fondateurs de l'europe ont dit plus
jamais la boucherie de 39-45 et les
fondateurs de l'europe on dit pour
éviter la boucherie de 39 45 il faut se
partager les ressources essentielles qui
sont justement celles pour lesquelles on
s'est tapé dessus parce que 1870 1914
1945 ça commence à faire beaucoup
et en fait la raison pour laquelle ça
commence à faire beaucoup c'est qu'on
avait les ressources qui a était
importante pour tout le monde le charbon
et l'acier qui était partagé entre les
allemands et les français puis avec la
veine chez les anglais
et ce qui a été au début de l'europe
c'est je me partage des ressources
énergétiques la ceca je me partage des
ressources agricoles le pac la politique
agricole commune et un deuxième partage
de ressources énergétiques y aura tom et
l'europe elle est venue de ça elle est
venue d'un souhait de vivre en harmonie
en se partageant les ressources
aujourd'hui il faut il revenir donc
l'énergie fossile qui entre en europe
redevient une ressource rare le climat
planétaire redevient une ressource rare
et préserver la paix quand on voit les
instabilités qui se développe à droite
et à gauche
à mon avis redevient un objectif
sympathique et bien si l'europe revenir
à ses fondamentaux
elle devra elle aussi abandonné l'idée
qu'il ya un seul grand marché intérieur
dans lequel je met en compétition les
roumains qu'il y ait 300 euros par an
par mois quand on est le français qui en
gagne 1200 et l'espagnol qui en gagnent
800 et l'allemand qui en gagne 2000 on
ne peut pas organiser correctement le
système de cette manière et le break
site est une réponse des anglais au fait
que à partir du moment où il ya plus de
croissance
ils n'ont pas envie de voir débouler
chez eux les européens qui gagnait 600
euros par mois parce qu'il en gagne 1200
au détriment des anglais qui en gagne un
peu plus donc le on va nécessairement
être obligé si on veut que l'europe
reste quelque chose de stable
je suis pas persuadé qu'on en prenne le
chemin mais on va nécessairement si on
veut que l'europe reste quelque chose de
stable de voir là aussi créé des forces
de frottement intérieur à l'europe parce
que l'europe est un agrégat aujourd'hui
deux pays qui ont des situations de
départ différentes et dont la
convergence dans la croissance n'est pas
possible donc il va falloir qu'on
organise le système donc c'est titre
cette idée intra européennes de
concurrence qui doit s'appliquer partout
elle est délétère dans tous les domaines
et même délétère chez nous par exemple
quand elle s'applique aux
infrastructures de long terme
j'ai nommé d'électricité j'ai nommé dans
pas longtemps le train si elle
s'applique de manière sauvage pour effet
de nous brouiller la vision de long
terme
si aujourd'hui on a tant de mal à
accoucher d'une vision de long terme
en ce qui concerne la production
électrique c'est entre autres et c'est
valable dans tous les pays
parce que le système a été désorganisée
par la concurrence qui raccourcit les
horizons de temps donc je ne suis pas du
tout contre la concurrence à partir du
moment où on est capable de réagir
rapidement un problème c'est très bien
d'être dans l'univers concurrentiel par
exemple ma société carbone 4 et dans
l'univers concurrentiel du conseil
je serai très malheureux que le conseil
devienne une activité de fonctionnaires
pense que ça ne marcherait pas bien donc
je suis très très content content moi de
rester dans l'univers concurrentiel
moyennant quoi j'ai des gros concurrents
en temps je te conseillerai kim selon
moi c'est pas juste
mais fondamentalement je pense que dans
ce domaine là c'est une bonne
organisation que d'avoir de la
concurrence
par contre de mettre de la concurrence
dans l'électricité était une connerie
sans nom et de mettre trop de
concurrence dans le ferroviaire ou
encore est un peu on peut faire des
délégations de service public sur la
desserte des régions
ça va bien de faire de l'open access sur
le tgv c'est une ânerie
donc on peut on peut en mettre un peu
mais d'en mettre trop à des effets
totalement contre-productif donc ce
raccourci les horizons de temps au début
pendant deux ans le consommateur est
ravi et derrière le truc se délite parce
qu'on investit pas et on l'a constaté
très bien soit
soit dit en passant voilà donc le la
question de la liberté pour un venir un
propos plus fondamental c'est très
facile de préserver la liberté de chacun
dans un univers en expansion
c'est la raison pour laquelle la
démocratie est née dans le premier pays
européen en tout cas c'est mon
explication dans le premier pays
européen qui a connu une période longue
de croissance c'est à dire la grande
bretagne et ça s'est étendu et c'est
apparu par ailleurs dans des pays qui
ont connu des périodes de croissance
importante
les états unis le pays le plus richement
doté en ressources naturelles au monde à
l'époque où il a été colonisé le plus
favorable à l'expansion humaine et celui
où la démocratie est la plus forte ou
faible sur dépend de ce qu'on veut
mettre derrière ce qualificatif la plus
forte c'est à dire là où pouvoir de la
base est le plus fort
la plus faible là où le pouvoir central
et plus donc le le la démocratie elle
est consubstantielle de la croissance
pour moi parce que il ya qu'en
démocratie qu'on puisse augmenter en
permanence les espaces de liberté de
chacun
sans que ça gêne les autres pour qu'on
est on augmente en permanence les
espaces de liberté de chacun sans ça
gêne les autres il faut que le système
global sont en expansion
si le système global est stable il est
impossible de donner plus à pierre sang
donné - paul donc là on est déjà dans un
système dans lequel c'est difficile de
promettre que la situation tout le monde
va s'améliorer or la démocratie va avec
des élections qui correspondent à cette
promesse pas il dans un système en
contraction c'est encore plus difficile
de faire ce genre de chose puisque
globalement la situation
les degrés de liberté de chacun se
réduisent donc le la question et c'est
consubstantiel de ce que je venais de
dire sur la question de la du commerce
donc la question de la liberté liberté
de commercer liberté d'entreprendre
liberté d'aller et venir comme bon vous
semble d'acheter ce que vous voulez et
c'est toutes ces libertés là seront
beaucoup plus délicate à gérer dans un
univers qui sera stable ou en
contraction c'est absolument évident et
c'est comme ce que je disais tout à
l'heure sur la le bon rationnement la
bonne manière de limiter les degrés de
liberté c'est de le faire délibérément
nous avec un critère qui comprend et
donc pour en revenir à ce que je disais
tout à l'heure
freiner les échanges ou non de la
préservation de l' actif naturel qui
s'appelle la planète terre et son climat
à peu près stables jusqu'à maintenant et
qui va se déstabiliser de plus en plus
c'est pas nécessairement un mauvais
alors je vois hello tout le monde quel
os tout le monde c'est pas une question
voilà avancée possible de faire ça le
poulpe bon ça je ne sais pas ça j'ai
répondu un plus bas à des questions
nucléaires quand même il ya plein de
questions sur nucléaire quelle serait la
durabilité de l'industrie nucléaire la
gestion des déchets tatati et tatata est
ce qu'un effondrement pour y arriver en
france à cause de la faillite et des f&a
alors ça c'est une bonne question
eh bien à mon avis la réponse est oui
alors je vais être un peu plus précis
car l'électricité aujourd'hui est un
système est essentielle au à court terme
au fonctionnement du monde
outre le fait que c'est essentiel au
fait que vous voyez ma première avis un
peu rouge je trouve sur mon écran sûr
pour ceux d'entre vous qui sont en train
de nous regarder l'electricite sans
électricité demain matin encore une fois
le monde s'effondre
vous n'avez plus alors de machines à
café c'est un drame
vous n'avez plus de frigo ou des plus
d'eau au robinet parce que c'est des
pompes qui vous alimente soro dans les
quelques rares système gravitaire on a
en france
vous n'avez plus de transports en commun
pour aller au travail dur et je n'avais
plus de travail parce que vous n'avez
plus de systèmes de communication vous
n'avez plus de banques
donc vous n'avez plus d'argent vous avez
pu vous n'êtes plus payé voilà les
magasins ne fonctionnent plus parce que
s'ils seront pas de caisse enregistreuse
donc ils vous demanderont rien et c'est
donc plus d'électricité demain matin le
monde s'arrête et du reste quand on
regarde la corrélation que certains
d'entre vous connaissent bien
énergie pib donc si vous la connaissez
pas vous allez sur mon site pour
regarder qu'est-ce que l'énergie
exactement et vous verrez la corrélation
dont je veux parler
eh bien elle est encore plus rectiligne
si tant est que ce soit possible sur
électricité pib il ya la correspondance
électricité pib et une droite absolument
parfaite dans tous les pays dans
lesquels j'ai regardé ça
donc ça veut dire que si demain matin
l'approvisionnement électrique devait se
retrouver rapidement contraint à la
baisse pour une raison indépendante de
notre volonté est bien nous aurions
instantanément une contraction
économique d'ampleur presque équivalente
alors c'est pas aussi simple que ça les
japonais ont montré qu'après fukushima
il était capable de survivre à une
baisse de la production électrique de 10
ou 15% alors les réacteurs nucléaires
faisait 30 dire pourquoi je vous sers
pas baissé de 30
ça va pas baisser de 30 parce qu'ils
avaient par ailleurs un parc de
centrales fossiles dont le facteur de
charge a instantanément augmenté en
particulier les centrales à gaz et en
pétrole
c'est très très net maintenant qu'on a
managé des statistiques sur
l'approvisionnement électrique partie
d'énergie primaire pour plein de pays
dans le monde
est ce cette marche de manoeuvre a
permis au japon de compenser quasiment
instantanément la baisse de
l'approvisionnement électrique c'est
très net sur les courbes de production
donc en fait ils ont eu à l'est quel
quelques pourcents de la baisse de
l'approvisionnement globalement mais pas
plus si on s'il avait vraiment eu 15 ou
20 % d'approvisionnement électrique en
moins
non non remplaçable là je peux vous dire
que l'économie japonaise aurait piqué du
nez beaucoup plus violemment après
vraiment de l'électricité est un bien
essentiel à court terme
alors une fois que j'ai dit ça au
essentielle à la stabilité de l'ensemble
revenons à idf et à son parc nucléaire
en ce moment ce qui est en train de se
passer c'est qu'on est en train de
[Musique]
créer une instabilité sur le parc
nucléaire qui est d'augmenter ses
charges et de baisser ses recettes alors
augmenté ses charges c'est par exemple
grand carénage
c'est à dire qu'on dit ben la centrale
telles qu'elles étaient donc à part il
faut rajouter des investissements sur
les centrales existantes et du coup au
lieu que et df disposent de centrales
amorties 40 ans les centrales sont
amorties et bien vous allez me rajouter
pour 50 milliards qui seront près de 60
pour que tout ça puisse continuer à
fonctionner pour qu'on rajoute des
charges de l'autre côté on continue à
développer des énergies renouvelables
intermittentes dans les énergies
renouvelables intermittentes à savoir le
soleil et le solaire et l'éolien ont la
caractéristique qui s'est très très bien
observé en allemagne de ne pas permettre
de supprimer de la puissance pilotable
dit autrement ça permet d'éviter du
combustible dans des centrales qui
existent et qui doivent exister pour
assurer le relais quand ya pas de soleil
ou pas devant mais ça ne permet pas de
supprimer les centrales en question
l'allemagne a fourni un très bel exemple
l'allemagne avait 100 gigawatts de
puissance pilotable charbon gaz
nucléaire hydroélectricité et gémit
biogaz aussi là dedans et charmant ce
charmant l'unita en 2002 elle a toujours
100 gigawatts de puissance pilotable
aujourd'hui avec une consommation
électrique est globalement est restée la
même
quand on regarde les espagnols les
espagnols ont augmenté l'installation de
puissance pilotable en même temps qu'ils
augmentaient l'installation d'éoliennes
et de panneaux solaires
donc dans tous les pays dans lesquels on
a fortement développé les modes
intermittents où on a dû conserver la
puissance pilotable existantes où on a
dû augmenter si la consommation
d'électrité local était en train
d'augmenter
donc je reviens en france j'augmente
l'éolien et le solaire
du coup ce que je vais faire c'est que
je ne vais pas supprimer des centrales
nucléaires je ne peux pas parce que
aujourd'hui le pacte social c'est que la
population n'accepte pas qu'un matin
d'hiver à cette heure c'est à dire y'a
pas de soleil et un jour où il y aura
pas de vente en anticyclone et bien la
machine à café ne fonctionne pas le
train pour m'amener au travail ne
fonctionne pas que je puisse pas faire
fonctionner mon bureau que je puisse pas
tirer de l'argent à un distributeur que
mon usines ne tournent pas que mon
magasin ne puisse pas accepter des
clients et que
les shops qui vend du café ne puisse pas
fonctionner aujourd'hui la collectivité
n'accepte pas l'idée que un jour sans
soleil et sans vent et bien chacun reste
chez soi où soit dit en passant il peut
rien faire non plus petit a pas
d'électricité peut pas monter dans
l'ascenseur au deuxième étage de la tour
pour ceux d'entre vous qui ont un
appartement au 20ème étage penser au
moment où l'ascenseur pourra plus être
utilisé
je sais pas quand donc voilà donc il ya
un sujet qui est que le pacte
aujourd'hui c'est que on est obligé de
d'avoir de la de l'électricité à tout
moment et parce qu'on est obligé d'avoir
de l'électricité à tout moment et bien
le on voit garder de la puissance
pilotable donc j'augmente les éoliennes
et les panneaux solaires
ce que la france est partie pour faire
parce qu'on pense que c'est une bonne
idée le pouvoir politique parce que
c'est une bonne idée je pense que cette
bêtise qui sert à rien à ce moment ça va
donc pas diminuer la puissance installée
mais ça va diminuer son facteur de
charge c'est-à-dire qu'elle tournera
moins souvent ou de manière moins
puissante
une fois que vous avez des centrales
dont la puissance est toujours là même
dont les coûts sont toujours les mêmes
parce qu'une centrale nucléaire en gros
ça vaut ses coûts de maintenance et de
maintien en état de fonctionnement qui
sont grosso modo indépendante sa
production puis ça vaut son
amortissement qui est indépendant de sa
production
ça vaut les travaux du grand carénage
qui sont indépendants de la production
donc c'est totalement que des coûts
fixes donc une fois que votre centrale
elle coûte ce qu'elle coûte quel que
soit ce qu'elles produisent ça dépend
pas de sa production
un peu comme une route une route la
route qui est en bas de chez moi elle
coûte ce qu'elle coûte à construire
ensuite qui passe une voiture de la dans
l'année où bill voiture dans l'année
voilà pour la centrale paris il ya une
fois que la centrale qui a des coûts
fixes elle est là des coûts de
production et pardon elle a des recettes
et là un facteur de charge qui baisse à
ce moment c'est recettes
si le mégawattheure reste constant
baissent et donc on se retrouve avec une
centrale qui a des coûts qui augmentent
et des recettes qui baissent là il
suffit d'attendre et armand il va se
passer quelque chose de désagréable
donc est-ce que ce qu'on est en train de
faire en ce moment pourrait un jour
conduire à un début alors d'effondrement
d'érosion économique
la réponse est assurément oui alors
après être plein de gens peuvent dire
c'est pas grave puisque toute façon faut
contracter l'économie pour résoudre le
problème climatique passe est une
manière comme une autre de faire le
résonnement qu'il peut se défendre
dit autrement si le gouvernement dit je
suis en train d'augmenter l'éolien et le
solaire parce que je veux contracté
l'économie française pour lutter contre
le climat moi j'ai rien à dire c'est un
raisonnement qu'il va assez bien
par contre si ils disent on fait ça
parce que ça permet de résoudre le
problème climatique
c'est une première escroquerie s'ils
disent on fait ça parce qu'il faut
diversifier les sources pour rendre le
système plus résilient là c'est une
erreur de jugement
c'est pas vrai malheureusement que ça va
se passer comme ça voilà donc le qu'est
ce qu'on est en train de faire pourrait
provoquer une instabilité dans le
système électrique en france
la réponse est parfaitement oui après
est-ce que plus largement c'est une
bonne idée ou pas de se passer du
nucléaire pour résoudre le problème
climatique
mon analyse c'est non et alors je vais
vous donner un parallèle qui vaut ce
qu'il vaut si vous êtes en train d'être
d'avoir une bactérie est de développer
une septicémie
est ce que c'est une bonne idée de ne
pas prendre des antibiotiques au motif
que ça pourrait vous donner des
problèmes gastriques et des problèmes
intestinaux et une éruption cutanée
le tout étant non mortels la réponse est
non une mauvaise herbe un mauvais
arbitrage de ne pas le faire et bien à
toutes proportions gardées de ne pas
recourir au nucléaire pour régler le
problème de climat c'est un mauvais
arbitrage
quand ça veut pas dire que s'ils ont
recours au nucléaire il faut se dire
youplaboum on peut se goberger autant
qu'on veut etc
je suis aussi partisan pour être très
clair de le faire pour amortir la
décroissance c'est à dire pour se donner
plus de temps pour gérer la décrue du
système il ya 2000 gigawatts de
centrales afin de 1200 maintenant
gigawatts de centrales à charbon dans le
monde
moi mon objectif c'est les supprimer le
plus vite possible
je suis pas dictateur je renvoie donc à
la première question de cet échange
mais par contre il est évident que plus
on se passent de nucléaire et qu'on va
garder ce charbon longtemps et donc plus
problème climatique va empirer et donc
plus on aura des déplacements de
populations à cause de problèmes
agricoles des guerres des troubles
géopolitiques des disparitions
d'écosystèmes des feux de forêt un peu
partout des coraux qui meurent à cause
de l'acidification l'eau qui monte et
qui finira pas vers les villes etc tout
ça arrivera plus vite si on dit qu'on
n'en veut pas pense que dans l'arbitrage
des risques c'est pas nécessairement la
meilleure manière de voir les choses
alors après pourquoi est-ce que c'est
pas ça qu'on est en train de faire je
vais finir là-dessus
tout simplement parce que ça renvoie à
la décision en monde démocratique
la décision en monde démocratique n'est
pas une décision qui se base sur les
faits c'est une décision qui se base sur
l'arbitrage des forces de pression donc
tous les gens qui m'écoutent en ce
moment et qui pensent qu'on est en train
de faire le mauvais arbitrage en disant
je mets mon argent dans les éoliennes et
des panneaux solaires beaucoup d'argent
pour faire baisser la provision de
nucléaire c'est un mauvais arbitrage
alors qu'on pourrait faire pour les
mettre cet argent dans des trains de la
laine de verre des pompes à chaleur du
biogaz et des subventions de
l'agriculteur pour qu'il fasse moins de
vaches et de meilleure qualité et bien
je les invite à s'exprimer de cette
manière sur tous les sites de débats qui
sont ouverts
éventuellement en contribuant aux
travaux du shift éventuellement relayant
ce genre d'information voilà si vous
adhérez au fait qu'il est urgent dans un
système qui est au bord de
l'effondrement
bien rangé des marges de manoeuvre un
peu l'ordre je vous invite à le faire
savoir pour tous vous pourrez autour
d'eux et là dessus je vais vous dire
bonsoir vous avez pu constater je me
suis même pas levé pour allumer la
lumière et donc il commence à se faire
tard je vous souhaite une très bonne fin
de soirée merci pour ceux qui sont
restés jusqu'à maintenant je voyais les
messages qui arrivent et des petites
bulles là c'est très joli et très
poétique et donc à une prochaine fois
j'espère au revoir